Kingdoms will fall heroes will rise and  a great warrior shall emerge and only  with his courage and his weapon of war  [Music]  programer I shouldn't be doing any of  this  you can thank you for that he's the one  I want to save money no no I just didn't  want to spend five million dollars on a  promo frankly I think this whole thing  is confusing do you guys have any idea  what a raven flying through the  landscape is supposed to look like I've  never seen a rose mythic quest Ravens  banquet you know what it's gonna sell it  I should take my shirt completely off  and get super greased up what does that  have to do with the video well that'll  still the reality what reality of a man  on a Thunderbird  [Music]  you